here's how a tangle teaser works when
you brush hair you're pushing all the
tangles to the ends and sometimes you
don't actually make it there because
there's so much compressed tangling
you've made a knot this means that
you're bending and stretching your hair
a lot more and this flexing is making
the glue on the inside of your hair the
CMC that's sticking your hair together
get really loose and eventually that
builds up enough for your hair to break
the bending also makes the cuticle scale
stick up and chip off more this is why
they tell you to detangle hair from the
bottom up so you're compressing less
Tangles with the tangle teas of the
bristles are really soft and bendy plus
they are smooth so if you have a knot
forming then there's more Force building
up and once it builds up too much the
bristle just like flops and gives up if
you try really hard it is possible to
just force your way through the knots
but this just kind of protects you from
yourself